how did you deal with feeling sorry for
yourself when your health was at its
worst I was told at a really young age
like when I got diagnosed with juvenile
rheumatoid arthritis I was in grade two
and my dad told me never use this as an
excuse so if you're laying in bed being
like why me it doesn't actually get you
out of it so I would try and harness
that self-pity and try to turn it into
anger cuz anger is more of a positive
emotion you can actually do something
with it like get angry get frustrated
and try to fix it do as much research as
you can and try things and just try them
and try them and try them until they get
better you have to get into the mindset
of I will do anything to get better
before I think you can get better